thing we discussed the most was how to
keep a consistency of tone and character
and so that it didn't feel like suddenly
they were different people when they
started singing and dancing that somehow
you would still feel like they were the
same people that you had just seen in
the scene beforehand there was kind of a
discussion that we all sort of had that
these characters recognize that when
they're together there's music between
them and then when we get to the fight
sequence and the record scratches you
know the music has died I think another
thing that we did to help was um
developing a like a rat tatat patter
between the two characters in the scenes
that weren't musical because there's a
musicality to that and there's a rhythm
to that it helps sort of keep the music
alive somehow uh even though there was
no actual
[Music]
music